is here if there are no prefer it's the
first time ever that we present the
robot to the public my name is Rebecca I
am one of the founder of several
transport systems and we founded the
company in 2010 we developed a robot and
this robot is for to park cars in a park
or are you go with a car directly in the
beetle transfer station which you see in
the back here and the goal of the
transfer station is that you have a very
bright and a very large area there that
he can park your car very comfortable
then after you have close to how you
lock your car to take your key with you
then our robot comes and talks the car
for you in the garage this this
technology is the technology of several
transport systems you can store up to
sixty percent more cars in a garage our
first installation is on the airport in
the standoff in germany since we have to
measure every car we need this for our
system so we need the lengths the list
and the height of any car and the
position of the wheels so we have the
exact debtors of the car and this make
sure that we don't damage your car